foreign
they take Xerox copies
[Music]
the companies forget what it means to
make great products
[Music]
it's amazing
have you ever heard of a company called
Xerox Once Upon a Time zerox was a
householder name in fact they were even
more than a household's name they were a
noun whenever someone referred to a
photocopy they would often call it
azerox and if that's still the case to
this day while photocopies was what
Xerox was most known for this was by no
means their only contribution for
example they created a commercial
computer that Xerox Auto before apple
and even IBM back in 1973. Xerox also
created the first concept of a laptop
computer in 1976. on top of this Xerox
even invented the ethernet cable and it
was Xerox Altos that were actually used
to create the internet and those are
just xerox's most notable contributions
Xerox is also credited with inventing
graphical user interfaces Laser Printers
computer generated bitmap images modern
text editors and even an object oriented
programming I think this statement from
Bill Gates when questioned about
stealing from Apple really sums up the
whole situation I think it's more like
we both had this Rich neighbor named
Xerox and I broke into his house to
steal the TV set and found out that you
Steve Jobs had already stolen it given
the historic significance of Xerox you
would think that Xerox would be a
trillion dollar giant like apple or
Microsoft or at least a background giant
like Oracle but none of this is the case
in fact after the.com bubble Xerox
stocks hold off and never recovered a
similar story can be seen with the
revenue numbers as well within just the
past 10 years xerox's Revenue has fallen
by 70 percent at least the company was
still consistently profitable wait never
mind it that just changed as well in the
last 12 months Xerox has literally lost
over a billion dollars and given that
they only have 930 million dollars left
in cash and it seems like a bankruptcy
is inevitable for the company especially
with the recession
so how did Xerox go from being a
household name responsible for leaps
within the computer industry to
balancing out on the verge of bankruptcy
taking a look back the roots of Xerox
date back way further than at any other
tech company mostly because they weren't
even created as a tech company Xerox was
established as a photographic paper and
equipment manufacturer in Rochester New
York in 1906. originally they were named
the haloid photographic company and
honestly they didn't do anything
noteworthy for the first 30 years it
appears that they were just a small
company that stayed a small company it
wasn't until 1938 that the tide would
start shifting for Xerox at the time an
independent physicist named Chester
Carlson was working on an invention that
could print images using an electrically
charged drum and a toner this invention
caught the eye of Joseph R Wilson the
son of xerox's co-founder over the next
several years Joseph who would have
tried to convince Chester to turn his
invention into a commercial product
Chester would finally agree to do so in
1946 and today Chester is actually
credited as one of xerox's co-founders
at this pointed Xerox finally had their
hands on a groundbreaking product but
this was only the first step they had to
actually convince the public to buy and
or use the darn thing and that's exactly
what Xerox would focus on over the next
decade the first thing they did was come
up with a name for the product initially
they would land on the term at
xerography which means dry riding in
Greek this would eventually evolve into
being Xerox the haloid company would
officially debut zerography at the
optical Society of America Convention on
October 22nd 1948 but at this point
xerography was still very much just a
concept while Xerox did have a working
prototype there was still a long way to
go in making it commercially viable that
was okay though this presentation was
mainly designed to generate and gauge
interest it appears that Xerox saw
enough interest for them to go ahead and
a trademark determined Xerox that same
year just one year after that Xerox
would come out with the model A which
became the world's first a zero graphic
copier but this too was by no means
optimal generating a single copy
required multiple steps and the Machine
very much required an expert to use but
Xerox kept iterating and after 10 years
they would create the world's first
automatic plain paper commercial copier
WD Xerox 914 that same year it would
create one of their most iconic
commercials of all time a simple
commercial showcasing how easy it was to
photocopy a page from a book using the
Xerox 914 nowadays this seems like an
ordinary day in the life of an office
worker but back in 1959 this was truly a
revolution for the first time people
could photocopy important documents and
substantially lessen the burden of
record keeping the hallowed company very
much knew what they had created and they
were so confident in the vision that
they would change the name of the entire
company to Xerox in 1961. and the rest
well the rest is history
thank you
Xerox was never that intent on selling
the 914 itself they far preferred a
renting model where users would have to
pay a fee for each photocopy they
charged users 25 per month to get access
to a 914 and then they charged an
additional 10 cents per copy customers
also had to pay for ink in the paper as
well which usually ran about 5 cents per
copy so the all-in cost was 25 per month
plus 15 cents per copy this translates
to 256 dollars per month plus 1.54 cents
per copy today the only person who
didn't rent the 914 was the US
government who refused to rent they
wanted to buy 914s outright and the two
would eventually settle on a price of 27
to 500 that's 281 000 per machine in
today's money clearly it the 914 was by
no means cheap but that didn't prevent
it from becoming an extremely popular
thanks to its usefulness within just two
years of launch Xerox would reach 69 in
Revenue Xerox would double down on the
marketing and make a commercial
showcasing that even a chimpanzee could
use the machine around the same time
Xerox would be listed on the New York
Stock Exchange which just created even
more hype for the company by 1965 it had
pulled in over 500 million dollars in
Revenue which translates to 4.7 billion
dollars today Xerox would follow up to
914 with several iterations such as the
813 the 420 the 720 the 330 and the
2400. all of these had slight variations
and were meant for slightly different
purposes for example the 2400 was a
duplicator as opposed to a photocopier
but all of these machines had the same
Indigo in mind make it cheaper and
easier to reproduce documents and given
that this had become an essential need
for businesses and individuals alike
Xerox was literally printing money but
while everything at Xerox was going
great Joseph Wilson was starting to get
old he would step down from being CEO in
1967 but he would serve as the chairman
up until his death in 1971. before he
died though he would oversee one last
project called a park or the Palo Alto
Research Center this is where all the
crazy inventions that we talked about
would come from computers laptops
ethernet the mouse email file servers
and who knows what else it seemed like
Xerox was very much planning to Pivot to
the PC industry they had the money the
expertise and even the technology so all
they had to do was pivot and the cash in
it but this pivot would never come
instead it Xerox just pushed all their
inventions under the rugged and focused
on their photocopiers at first this
actually worked out fine Xerox was
expanding internationally and they were
becoming a household's name even in
developing countries zerhogs had
basically become synonymous with the
photocopies and for Xerox it probably
seemed like nothing could ever go wrong
given that they had cornered such an
essential Market but as we now know it
that was simply not the case
looking back there was no pivotal moment
that screwed over Xerox rather it was
just Decades of complacency and
ignorance I mean Outsiders understood
xerox's potential better than Xerox
themselves and I think the best example
of this is a story with Steve Jobs in
1979 Steve agreed to give Xerox
somewhere between five and eight percent
of Apple in return for a mere one
million dollars the condition for this
investment thougha was that Steve would
get access to xerox's Palo Alto Research
Center Steve would end up ripping off
the window icon menu and the pointing
device systems from Xerox into new Apple
Computers but at this point you can't
even blame Steve for copying given that
Xerox literally opened the doors for him
Steve would later say quote they just
had no idea what they had you could say
the same thing about the Apple stake
that they received as well first take
would have been worth 150 billion
dollars today Xerox could have at least
waited for Apple's IPO to solid stake
but instead Xerox would end up flipping
the stake for a disgusting uh 1.2
million yeah Xerox truly had no idea
what they were doing it seems that their
leadership was just so high under
success within the photocopying industry
that they didn't even care that there
was quandering such massive
opportunities eventually Xerox would try
to take a step into the computer
industry but their attempt was pathetic
and ridiculous in 1981 they launched the
Xerox star which was based on the Xerox
Alto the computer itself worked just
fine it had a nice user interface
respectable hardware and productive
software but there was one major
shortfall the darn thing cost 16
000 which translates to over 50 G's
today given that people could get a
comparable machine from IBM for less
than 1600 I don't think you'd be
surprised here that the Xerox star
flopped like a fish out of water the
worst part is that the Xerox didn't even
try to salvage the situation they
basically went oh well we tried and it
didn't work back to photocopying and I
think this mindset is what really killed
his Xerox they were just so comfortable
with photocopying and it was so
profitable that they didn't even care to
expand this mindset was just made it
even worse by the fact that they didn't
face any consequences for this behavior
in fact they were being rewarded as
computers and the internet grew in
popularity so did the need to print and
photocopy documents combine this with
the.com bubble and Xerox stock would go
vertical between 1982 and 1999 Xerox
stock would rocket 900 despite making
virtually no real progress after the.com
Bubble Burst though xerox's House of
Cards would topple over and all that
remained was the real Xerox
foreign
if Xerox had just leveraged one of the
many inventions that they helped create
whether that be computers servers or the
internet they would be a mega giant
today but instead it they're on the
brink of bankruptcy with the same
valuation that they were at 40 years ago
oftentimes we hear about corruption
great and terrible reputations topple
massive companies but when it comes to
Xerox the factor that actually toppled
them was simply too much success the
success of blinded them from the need to
continue innovating and expanding
instead it they just sat on their butts
while their empire crumbled from
underneath them with the rise of
electronic documents e-signatures and
personal printers people simply don't
need to go to Office Depot to make
photocopies in fact if anything they'd
prefer to back up all their documents to
the cloud instead of keeping track of
physical copies at this point Xerox is
trying to sell an outdated product to a
shrinking market and to be honest
there's only one way this ends
bankruptcy but that's just what I think
did you realize how much of our modern
Technologies are attributable to Xerox
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're grateful for xerox's
contributions and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one
foreign